pues el ambiente es bastante interesante
desde hace ya tres días por la noche
están estos reflectores grandes que
salen precisamente desde el lado
sudoeste del pentágono que fue donde
estrelló el vuelo 77 de american
airlines este vuelo había salido del
aeropuerto internacional de bus y pues
se estrelló en este lado allá en ese
lugar del pentágono que no logramos ver
desde acá porque está con mucha
seguridad y es donde en las horas de la
tarde el presidente yo bailé también
estará presente al lado de la
vicepresidenta cámara jarvis desde allá
pues es donde precisamente sale este
reflector que ha iluminado la noche acá
en washington durante los últimos tres
días y donde se harán también eventos
después de este evento o esta tarde en
acá en el pentágono el presidente job
alguien tiene planeado salir para su
casa en delaware y pues bueno
hay muchas expectativas sobre lo que no
solamente pasar a la nueva york sino
como lo decía el momento pasará después
shanksville en pensilvania y después lo
que venga a decir acá el presidente yo
vaya
y esto no en cuántas personas perecieron
en el pentágono y cómo se modificaron
los protocolos después del ataque en la
sede de seguridad más importante del
país
claro fueron
184 personas que murieron en ese vuelo
77 de american airlines
como obviamente
sobrevivientes obviamente como pasó en
nueva yor mucha gente estuvo con sus
cámaras tomando un vídeos tomando fotos
de lo que ocurrió claro esto fue un
antes y un después en cuanto a la
seguridad aérea civil desde ese momento
hasta el 14 de septiembre los
aeropuertos los más de 400 aeropuertos
400 34 aeropuertos aproximadamente que
hay en eeuu pues cerraron todos los
aviones estuvieron en tierra hasta el 14
de septiembre del 2001 cuando ya el
presidente
entonces presidente george w.bush ordenó
a la guardia civil ya otros dos cuerpos
de la fuerza pública pues hacer
presencia en los aeropuertos en los
principales aeropuertos de la ciudad del
país para empezar a reactivar entonces
la aviación y desde ahí empezaron los
protocolos nuevos protocolos nuevos como
por ejemplo empezar a quitarse los
zapatos después de que meses después de
estos atentados del 11 de septiembre del
2001 una persona que viajaba de parís a
miami trató de meter explosivos en sus
zapatos y detonarlos en el vuelo a
partir de entonces por ejemplo las
personas empezaron a tener sentar los
zapatos antes de montarse los aviones a
tenerse que quitar en los cinturones a
pasar a los electrónicos los líquidos
porque todos estos artefactos eran
usados por potenciales terroristas para
pues un eventual ataque a un avión o en
un aeropuerto desde entonces sin embargo
lo que resaltan los analistas de
seguridad es que precisamente desde esos
atentados del 11 de septiembre acá en
eeuu no ha habido un atentado terrorista
mayor mayúsculo en los aeropuertos y en
la aviación civil estadounidense y pues
a pesar de las críticas que de las
críticas que hay frente a la seguridad
de transporte aéreo en este país lo que
se resalta es que no ha habido
precisamente un ataque terrorista desde
entonces de gran magnitud en el área la
aviación civil en eeuu